Colorado trial considers whether the
14th Amendment disqualifies Trump some
constitutional experts argue that a
clause in the amendment should bar
Donald J Trump from becoming president
again but that view is far from
Universal among legal Scholars now the
big story that they're not getting into
in a lot of these articles one article
just said the judge donated to a li to
liberals here's a here's the tweet from
Mike Davis he says new Denver District
Judge Sarah Wallace a Democrat donor
commits reversible error by refusing to
recuse from Trump January 6th case after
donating to anti-trump January 6th P so
let's just get to the specifics here
October 15th 2022 Sarah Wallace donated
to the Colorado turnout project a
political action committee formed to
vote out Republicans who supported Trump
on January 6th 2021 and quite literally
as now specifically in Colorado but
that's what they're saying they say we
formed shortly after Colorado
Republicans refused to condemn the
political extremists who stormed the
capital on January 6 in fact Republican
rep Lauren bobert even encouraged the
violence that's not true she did not
encourage violence it's absurd but
that's what their argument is and with
those lies the judge in this case has
donated to this
organization and is now overseeing the
question of whether or not Trump should
be removed so you know if you thought
there was going to be a fair hearing on
this one you were wrong now it may be
for political reasons the judge can't
just say Trump is off the ballot but
Michigan is next and here's the best
part in Michigan the challenge is not
with Donald Trump someone sued the
Secretary of State saying that Trump
should be removed and when Trump's
lawyers tried to intervene saying like
hey there's no Insurrection here they
said you have no standing you are not
party to this lawsuit now that's a
clever one next up is Minnesota and uh
I'll tell you what I think I think uh
some point next year there is a strong
probability that one state will
unilaterally at the last minute take
Trump's name off the ballot and here's
the important thing I was mentioning
this earlier on the Tim pool Daily Show
My Morning podcast a lot of people are
like yeah but where where where are they
going to succeed with one of these
things right is it going to be a swing
state and then like a Democrat district
judge says you know okay Trump's off the
BT but then the state challenges it and
it's no imagine a state like California
takes Trump's name off the ballot and
then let's say Trump does win but the
but he Lo the popular vote by 5 to 10
million votes the Democrats are then
going to say see look Trump he's how
does he win the presidency but lose the
popular vote by 10 million and it's
because in states with massive po
Republican populations like California
but they're so heavily Democrat they can
remove his name from the ballot Trump
doesn't get the general Republican votes
in the a decent amount and then it looks
like Trump did not actually win the the
popular vote because they' removed him
that's another game they might play but
I'm curious what uh what y'all think
well you need is one state if you get
one state you have President and then
the other ones can go and follow suit if
they do that I mean we're so third world
at that point the fact that this is even
being considered this judge should be
thrown off the case you you donate to a
pack that is focused they're only
focused on bobert in Colorado but
they're actually focused on everybody
with the mentality that Trump won the
election anybody that's Maga they want
out well she donated money to it she
should be thrown so far off the case she
says that she doesn't remember I mean
that's the quote that Colorado Republic
radio is running with that she donated
$100 and her justification was well I
don't remember making that donation and
I didn't know what their uh the mission
of this organization was well she's too
stupid she needs to fix it doesn't seem
like a great judge right this is
questionable all
around I think that's the point though
like the the the substance of the case
doesn't really matter it's obviously
that they're after Trump they're looking
at for any excuse they can come up with
so I mean I don't have a whole ton to
add just because it's it's blatant and
clear and the idea that the American
public accepts it is probably the most
the thing that I have the most problem
with is the is not just that this is
happening it's that people are so
disengaged and uninterested or you know
comfortable with this type of behavior
it means that the the fundamental uh
ideals that our country are founded on
people don't have any respect for them
at all anymore no massive protests out
there no nothing nobody's even talking
about I think you have to give credit to
uh Jason Miller who's with the Trump
campaign who was the one who was like
this is happening this judge donated to
this cause and it's one of the only
quotes that I have seen circulated at
all I mean this detail that she has
donated that she is essentially a biased
judge from the beginning and we know
about it and she was the one to decide
well I'm not going to accuse myself is
crazy and I think this is the type of
case that they'll just try over and over
again until something sticks and if it's
not this if they run out of 14th
Amendment arguments they'll shift to
another claim against Trum look so look
Trump's lawyers argued if they're even
going to pursue this argument Trump has
to have been convicted under the federal
statute pertaining to rebellion and
Insurrection specifically created to
deal with the 14th Amendment and he has
not been they're doing it anyway and and
already the judge said no it doesn't
matter we can I I think she should
recuse herself from this case and when
it comes to him it's like justice is
blind they do whatever they want to do
nobody is protesting nobody is fighting
against it or anything it's time for
people to stand up and stop being afraid
we got to stick together we got to fight
through this because if they could do
that to him then which one of us is next
oh worse than that right what they can
do to Trump they can do to you tenfold
uhhuh they just come and shoot us in the
head the New York Times says judge
Wallace has laid out nine topics to be
addressed the trial which is scheduled
to last all week they include whether
section three of the 14 amendment
applies to presidents what Enga what
what engage AED and Insurrection mean
under that section whether Mr Trump's
actions fit those definitions and
whether the amendment is self-executing
in other words whether it can be applied
without specific action by Congress
identifying whom to apply it to so the
14th Amendment section three
specifically says representative or me
or uh member of the Senate it
specifically says elector of the
president or vice president and then it
says uh and may not hold office civil or
military and so the argument people are
making is that the reason why Section 3
outlines the the exact elected positions
and then says civil office is because it
views them it views a distinction civil
office meaning a bureaucratic job you're
appointed to whereas the other positions
you're elected to so it would seem their
argument is oh Trump can be president
because president isn't specifically
addressed here but that's that's a tough
question because I don't know civil
office by I'm not going to sit here and
say the silly argument from the from the
left they say you know a well-regulated
militia means government regulation when
that's not what regulated mean meant
back then back then regulated meant like
well equipped and and and properly armed
with clean materials and so perhaps
civil office meant something specific
back then it doesn't mean today I guess
we're going to hear but but regardless
of this I think it's absolutely silly to
be having the the hearing at all yeah
the fact that when it came to 2020 the
majority of the lawsuits coming from
Trump were dismissed on standing and not
the merits right and then you see a case
like this where there's literally no
merit whatsoever but they hold it Anyway
come on legal system is is is well I'll
put it this way I'm not I'm not so
convinced as to say the legal system is
completely broken but Republicans don't
file lawsuits anyway so we wouldn't know
no we just sit back and get destroyed
every single time we're weak and we let
them run all over us you're talking
about definitions they don't care about
definitions they write the rules they
rewrite them if they don't work for them
they don't care we make the third world
look like beautiful right now what
they're doing to us it's ridiculous so I
I don't think we stand a chance against
this kind of stuff unless we get smart
and get smart quick as long as as long
as Ron McDaniel is running R she should
be fighting this what's she doing
getting more Botox or something I it's a
joke it is it is unconscionable that not
only is she still in her position but
Donald Trump was talking positively
about her just the other day and I don't
know what is wrong with that man to to
not see that two elections were run
absolutely horribly the Democrats
absolutely outworked the Republicans
they made the Republicans look like
fools and it was sign the significant
portion of it was ground game I believe
that that Donald Trump would have won in
2020 had it not been for the Republicans
being so bad at their job because they
let the Democrats do uh change the the
laws in in no in Pennsylvania they were
in on it in Pennsylvania the Republicans
teamed up with Democrats to change the
rules in violation of their own
Constitution well and Ron McDonald knows
and Trump knows this too that the RNC
needs Trump I don't believe Trump knows
things I think TR I think I mean we have
to look back at the debate right Ron
mcdonal puts out this first statement
being like it would be a mistake to miss
the debate this is a bad idea but they
know they need Trump to bring in the
viewership that's how they are going to
generate money off of this fundraising
right I every fundraising email is get
your Trump gold card and then you look
at the bottom and it's always the RNC
the r that that's money doesn't go to
trump it goes to her and her sick people
around that place they know they him on
so many levels and I wish that Trump
would do more to hold him accountable to
that they need him so much more than
Republicans on the state level need the
RNC to be better at organizing I don't
know that Trump's supporters who you
know would follow him into a burning
building necessarily would turn out for
every single person he endorses on with
the same enthusiasm and that's actually
what the RNC needs to get get serious
about in my opinion you've been on the
campaigns longer than I have but yeah
it's just a lot of times the RNC just
ignores the campaign you see people I
think you're going to have J.R majusi on
later this week he got screwed by these
people I mean they don't take the time
to actually work with the good
candidates they work with the candidates
are going to be medable to what they
need them to do which is go with the
status quo go along with what gets along
kick back your money to us so that we
have our funded operation it's all a
money game and it's all a joke it's like
the GOP is in competition with the
libertarian party for the most useless
party in America yeah it is ridiculous
and I think there's just a cultural
understanding I think you know they are
definitely not the counterculture
anymore but for all the years the DNC
said we're the oppressed ones we're the
counterculture come volunteer with us be
active with us I mean it did translate
into people who are willing to knock on
doors and to be more active on a
Grassroots level RNC says grabs Roots
but I don't think it actually has strong
organizations and I know the argument
you know rural versus whatever I don't
think that it's about that I think that
it's I think that the temperament of
people that are conservative it's harder
to get them to be activist types
um I think that you see people that are
that are progressives or or that are
upset with the status quo it's far
easier to motivate people like that to
get out and and get a do things you know
have a ground game be activist the the
people that are that are Republicans or
conservatives that tend to be kind of
activists they tend to do things with
with like their church or whatever
whereas the left it's it's homeless
shelters and you know food not bomb and
and know that kind too we have risks
like you know you go out and you put
yourself out as a conservative you live
in an urban area she can tell you she
gets more death threats than anyone I
know it it's ridiculous what we go
through so we can't run around all of us
don't have The Bravery to say yeah I'm a
conservative yeah I'm going to go
organize no you might get really hurt
well I think that's the problem is that
conservatives tend to be cowards yeah
well not this one cuz last year anytime
every day I'm very vocal very bold and
I'm out there and what I saw last year
from a lot of candidates that really put
their heart out there to sold gave it
everything they had ran on that American
first platform we got like no support
from the party that is that is
unconscionable and it's not a surprise
you look at people like uh Scott presler
who's probably the most effective
conservative uh activist when it comes
to actually getting people to vote and
getting people register
and I I can't understand why the RNC and
Rona McDonald's aren't like giving this
guy every every single bit of help that
they could possibly muster for him he's
effective I think it's twofold though
they'd have to admit that they are doing
something wrong and they need him and
there's an ego and pride there they
don't want to but also the RNC you know
has its own behind the scenes politics I
think about when Larry Elder challenged
Gavin Newsome in the recall right and
the RNC even though he emerged as the
leader the RNC did not give him the
support they should have right and
theoretically that is one of the most
important and I think under talked about
political battles that we had in recent
history and the RNC did not even give
him the fighting support that he needed
in my opinion uh there is a disconnect
between what the voters want and what
the administrative size of that wants I
mean it is sad but you know to your
point they ultimately know where the
money as they know the supporter is
that's why they invoke Trump's name when
it's convenient to them and they like to
be in the opposition because raise more
money if you can send an email that says
we're being screwed they're going to
kill us all we're destroyed Biden's
ruining us than if you talk about
results and it's sad but it's true it's
infuriating because that that
ineffectiveness and that desire to be
the underdog is part of the reason why
the whole of the culture is so run by
the left and it translates to all the
anti-Semitism and stuff that's going on
in in college campuses now if the
Republicans gave people something to
Aspire to the Republican party I mean if
they gave people something to Aspire to
you wouldn't have the left dominating
everywhere in our society and the left
does dominate every institution in our
society right now and it's starting to
have realworld consequences and you're
seeing it in the you know case in point
the all the anti-Semitism and all the
people that hate the Jews and stuff that
that you see in college campuses Le I'm
curious what your experience is as uh a
conservative I mean were you always a
republ how did you get to where you are
well like I said with the food bank I
always had to be vocal get out there
roll elbows with the politicians so what
C my attention and I'm going say it
again I always say it for so far as
myself and so many other black
conservatives was that when Trump said
in 2020 why don't y'all run and take
back your Community because they're not
helping you anyway so that's what caught
my attention and that's when I decided
to change and become a
conservative and did your community
react positively negatively I mean did
other black conservatives decide they
they would support you well it wasn't I
didn't really care if they supported me
or not you know I don't give a damn
about that but um so what really I think
that so far as my community you know
they don't give a damn they know when
they need to help they can come to me
I'm in the streets I'm with the homeless
I'm with anybody that's hurting and need
of help I'm there but um the community
supported me but it was just um you know
with the Twitter page people start
coming after me calling me all kind of
derogatory names and um you know the
coons the and everything else that come
along with that and uh you know I guess
they most of them didn't know exactly
who they was talking to but they quickly
found out I like that response I think
that's really funny cuz I think they
thought I was going to be afraid you
know because they call me all the ugly
names that that would run me away from
the party so no thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8:00 pm and become a member over at
timcast.net thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all next
time